speaking of tampa the tempeh buccaneers
will be in washington on saturday night
on nbc washington is a significant
underdog as we would expect one of the
reasons we don't know about the
availability of alex smith will he play
at all we think he will if he plays
though we may still see a rotation
between him and taylor heineke here's
heineke from earlier this week talking
about his comfort level currently in the
washington offense
there's not much that's changed with
scott over the over the years uh
playbook wise um a couple wrinkles here
and there um those were something to
kind of get through um you know with
just different reads on the same plays
and stuff like that it kind of changes
from week to week
um
but again you know i i feel very
comfortable and scott turner's offense i
feel like i know it like the back of my
hand and um again it's just about going
out there and execute and that's that's
the biggest thing
heineken took the majority of the snaps
at practice on thursday peter alex smith
still limited with a calf injury there's
kind of a vibe
that they're moving toward having smith
ready to go antonio gibson there
starting running back ready to go he's
got turf toe terry mclaren star receiver
ankle walking boot a week and a half ago
ready to go the question is how
effective will they be and at
quarterback how much taylor heineke will
we see
and look you got to do what you got to
do to try to get the w
i i i
i prefer one guy to be playing the
position but if a rotation helps you if
you think it's going to help you then so
be it that's what you need to do if
you're on
rivera yeah i think if you're rivera you
basically are waking up saturday morning
and when you get to the stadium you're
asking alex smith okay level with me
you know i need to know about your
situation and you go out on the field
before the game it's not urgent that
taylor heineke knows at you know 1 p.m
or
6 30 p.m how much he might play in this
game i mean he's just got to be ready to
go he's got to be a classic relief
pitcher in this game
mike i would be very surprised
you know if alex smith
doesn't start and if he doesn't play the
majority of this game
you know mike i i know alex smith i
don't know him
very well but i know him enough
to believe
that what he is thinking going into this
game is
listen
i've been playing with house money all
year
and
i'm smart i've seen it happen in san
francisco i've seen it happen in kansas
city
they are going to either draft my
replacement
or sign my replacement here
they're not going with my history
they're not going to build a playoff
contender around a quarterback who
almost had his leg amputated two years
ago
and who really is not the same player
that he was
okay i think alex smith's a realistic
guy and in my opinion i think alex smith
badly wants to play in this game he
wants to duel tom brady you know to the
end
and i i don't know i've been thinking
this all week if he gets on the field at
the start of the game unless he
aggravates it i bet he plays
you know something just occurred to me
as you were talking about alex smith and
the future of the quarterback position
in washington we have 12 teams playing
this weekend
for six of the teams the quarterbacks
very well may be playing their last
games ever for that team if not ever all
together from alex smith
to
drew brees ben roethlisberger phillip
rivers
tom brady
maybe mitchell trubisky with the bears
right
i doubt that of all those guys i doubt
that brady
is the one who would be playing his
final game for the buccaneers in large
part because i highly doubt that they'll
lose but half of the quarterbacks
playing this weekend could be the last
time they put on the uniform for that
team
i don't know if it's a factor or not i
don't know if it's a positive or a
negative if it makes you think a little
too much a little too emotional too
reflective but i can't remember a time
when we've had a playoff weekend with
that many quarterbacks where you look at
it and you say yeah this may be it for
you with this team or for good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports